عطله العاصمه السعوديه الرياض متصدره
للمشهد الفني عالميا في حفل الاسطوري
بجوائز وورد 20 23
[موسيقى]
اكيد نحن العالم عربي واحد بدي قلك عبر
العربيه انه ااه نعم اوروبا الجديده هي في
الشرق الاوسط وعلى راسها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن عالم واحد نحن نمبر وان باذن
الله هنكون مثل ما ولي العهد قال لنا ان
شاء الله هذا فخر لنا شكرا على الاشياء
هذه جميله وهمم
قالها مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ فوق
الخيال احنا قاعد نعيش فوق الخيال هذا
الاحتفاليه اللي انا دائما اقول اي
احتفاليه هذه تمت زراعه شجره لتصبح مظل
الفن بتصبح مركز الفن لنقول للعالم انه
مركز الفن القادم من يوم ورايح هو المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الموسم الثالث من جو- وورد اضاف جائزه
جديده تحت اسم صناع الترفيه الماسيه تم
تقديمها لرئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم
اللي تشوفونه الان في الرياض هو البدايه
بدايه بسيطه جدا العمل مهما كان القياده
مكه واعطه واذا ما في رجال ينفذون على
الارض مثل الرجال هذا اللي قاعد قدامنا
معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
ومثله رجال اخرين اليوم موجودين عملوا عمل
مستحيل وجبار كما تم تكريم فنانين من حول
العالم بجوائز فخريه خاصه بصناع الترفيه
وجوائز الانجاز مدى الحياه وشخصيه العامه
وكان للراحلين نصيب من الحضور في الحفل
رغم غيابهم
[موسيقى]
حصد فيلم كيرا والجن على جائزه الفيلم
المفضل يعني مين هيكسب الجائزه يعني
الافلام كلها حلوه يعني وجودنا هنا هو ده
الحاجه كويسه
الممثله الافضل والممثل الافضل سينمائيا
للفنانه هند صبري والفنان احمد عز واهم
حاجه ان احنا الاثنين معنا مفتاح البيت
يعني فاللي هي مش هيكسب ااا معه مفتاح
فيما حققت اغنيه شكرا للفنانه اصاله لقب
الاغنيه المفضله كلنا عم نتنافس لحب الناس
يعني هذه اهم شيء وبالنهايه اذا عم نتنافس
بتكون منافسه شريفه لنقدم الافضل للناس
دائما وحققت المطرب انغام لقب الفنانه
المفضله ولقب الفنان المفضل ذهب للمطرب
عبد المجيد عبد الله
وجودنا كلنا بعتبروا نجاح بحد ذاته
وتقدير
لكل الاعمال اللي عم بنقدمها
ان شاء الله
شوف انا هالايام مغرم عبد المجيد
والباقين يستاهلون جائزه الوجه الجديد
المفضل موسيقيا كان من نصيب الفنانه جوري
قطان
حسن هتاخذ الجائزه ولا تروح عليك انت ايش
تقول
انا لو قلت هتخرب الدنيا
من الحب فاطمه
وجائزه المؤثر المفضل ذهبت لاحمد الشقيري
في تنظيم المهرجانات امانه يعني حضرتنا
الاول حضاره الثانيه والان هذا الثالث
يعني التوهج يزيد سنه عن سنه قاعد يزيد
التوهج بشكل فوق التخيل
وخطف النجم اشرف حكيمي جائزه الرياضيه
المفضل وجائزه الرياضيه المفضله خطفتها
مريم صالح بالله
شكرا جزيلا انا سعيد بتواجد في هذا البلد
لليله خاصه نستمتع فيها انا وعائلتي شكرا
لدعمكم
مسلسل صالون زهره على جائزه المسلسل
المفضل صالون زهره صادق الصباح قاعد يعني
يشتغل شغل يجنن المشاهدين ليش لا والله
بالعكس عشان اسلم المشاهدين
والحقيقه انه الواحد يجرب ينوع بالاعمال
كما حصل على جائزتي الممثله المفضله
والممثل المفضل الدراميا الفنانه نادين
نجيم والفنان ابراهيم حجاج
ان شاء الله يا رب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله في رمضان يارب
قول والله كمان والله ليش انت بتعرف يعني
احساس
بلا سالتك حاج تحكي
لانه عمل حلو على وجهك يكون هيك
توقف صحافه تضرب بالرمل
[ضحك]
هيلدا ياسين
صراحه انا دائما اقول انه احنا فعلا جيل
محظوظ والمسؤوليه علينا اكبر
للعاصمه السعوديه للسير على السجاده
البنفسجيه في واحده من ابرز ليالي موسم
الرياض
سعود الخلف العربيه الرياض
[موسيقى]